a shame you change set Blatter arrives  at the Congress in Zurich it's crunch  time for the most powerful man in world  football after 17 years leading FIFA  Blatter is seeking a fifth term as  president the world governing body is  facing the biggest crisis in its history  but Blatter promised a soul foot was  problems if reelected ugly today I'm  appealing for team spirit and unity so  we can move forward together I'll say  ensemble it may not always be easy but  it is for this reason that we are  gathered here today to tackle the  problems that have been created and try  to solve them you want a take pee yes a  division we will not solve them in one  day but we are going to tackle them  immediately with home with you Blatter's  soul challenger prince ali bin Al  Hussein of Jordan has the support of  most european football associations but  barring an upset it's unlikely he'll be  able to defeat Blatter to become for  next president of FIFA